how do we find the inverse of matrix a
here it's a 3x3 matrix this time the
formula for a inverse that we saw in the
previous lesson is valid for all square
matrices it's equal to one over the
determinant of a multiplied by the
adjoint of a no elementary operations
needed the condition states that the
determinant of a must not be equal to
zero that's because the denominator
cannot be equal to zero if the
determinant of a is zero then we can say
that the inverse of matrix a does not
exist so that's the first thing we
should do we find the determinant of a
we can have the first row as the
reference because we've already solved
innumerable determinant problems let's
go through this quickly the element two
will be multiplied with this determinant
to get this two multiplied with 1 times
0 minus 2 times 1 the next element is
minus 1 we get this - because we are
multiplying this product with minus 1
raised to 1 plus 2 the last element for
the first row is 0 because it's 0 it
doesn't matter what it's multiplied with
the product will always be 0 this will
be the value of the determinant this
part in the brackets will equal 0 minus
2 which equals minus 2 2 times minus 2
will equal minus 4 what about the second
product inside the brackets we have 0
minus 2 which equals minus 2 1 times
minus 2 is minus 2 and this product is 0
minus 4 minus 2 will equal minus 6 we
have the determinant now it's minus 6 as
it's not equal to 0 we can say that it's
non singular the inverse of this matrix
exists so we can move on to finding the
adjoint of a now to find the adjoint we
first find the matrix of cofactors of
each of the elements and then find the
transpose of that matrix so let's find
the cofactors of each of the elements
now
the first element is to its cofactor
will equal minus 1 raised to 1 plus 1
times its minor its minor is the
determinant of what's left after
excluding its row and column so the
cofactor will equal 1 multiplied by 0
minus 2 minus 2 the cofactor of this 2
is minus 2 now we come to the cofactor
of minus 1 it will equal minus 1 raised
to 1 plus 2 times 0 times 0 minus 2
times 1 minus 1 times minus 2 is 2
similarly we get the cofactor of 0 as
minus 1 now please pause the video take
your time and solve for the remaining 6
cofactors these are the six remaining
cofactors this transpose will give us
the adjoint of matrix a to find the
transpose we interchange the rows and
the columns the first row will become
the first column minus 2 2 minus 1 the
second row will be the second column 0 0
minus 3 and lastly the third row will
become the third column minus 2 minus 4
2 now we have the adjoint as well and
because we have both we can find a
inverse now let's write it here 1 over
determinant of a will be 1 over minus 6
we multiply this with the adjoint of a
what will this be equal to this is the
adjoint to get this we multiply this
scaler with each element of the adjoint
1 over minus 6 times minus 2 will equal
1 over 3 1 over minus 6 times 0 will
equal 0 1 over minus 6 times minus 2
will equal 1 over 3 again and like
always I want you to find the remaining
six elements remember we need to
multiply each of the elements with this
scaler
these are the six elements you should
have got this is a inverse we found it
using this formula so this was pretty
long but still faster than using an
elementary operation remember the
formula a inverse is equal to 1 over the
determinant of a time's the adjoint of a
you